this T wa'n't robe with collider and I
am here with the good folks behind the
art of self defense how are you guys
doing great ready before we get started
I just want to give a huge thank you to
supper sweet to Blue Moon to every all
of our sponsors for letting us be here
because covering South by cost money and
we've had some amazing sponsors and I
just want to give a huge thank you to
all of them let me start by saying how
much I enjoyed this movie from now on
I'm just gonna call you sensei and write
100% so I'm just curious if this true
are not true right off the bat this
movie only happened because you want to
talk about face off every day on set for
like a few weeks we talked about it a
split second right I think my dad my dad
was big you guys know we talk about it
for way more than a ton second I didn't
remember you in it and then when I
watched the trailer then I didn't
remember like a spot-on impression of
you and the airport scene on the tarmac
I was basically playing you yeah yeah
he's my little brother hey hey what do I
go I go on the plane that was you forced
which is where do we go oh that's the
plane okay okay I don't have a flat a
flowy jacket so I'm the nerdy one so you
didn't answer the question true or not
true true pretty um I really enjoyed
this and it has a very unique voice and
a very very unique dialogue in a cool
world talk a little about the like where
this idea came from and the germination
of the project I've been doing jiu-jitsu
for a little while now I've been I want
to say like five and a half six years
and it's become such a important part of
my life but a few years ago when I
started writing the script I was around
2015 I would just kind of started
getting into it and I knew that I wanted
to set something in the world of martial
arts cuz I was I had a passion for and I
thought that that could be an
interesting kind of world to play around
in but I didn't want to go
the expected route per se in terms of
where the story was going to go
we definitely start the movie off in a
more traditional kind of story structure
of like I want to say like a sports
movie or something where you know that
the characters gonna have a problem with
beginning and they're gonna try to
better themselves and at the end they're
gonna overcome or you hope they're gonna
overcome and we really didn't want to do
that so we we started it that way
halfway through there's definitely a
moment where the audience is it's told
the movie that you thought you're
watching is not the movie that you
thought that you are watching and we
just went forward with that
balls-to-the-wall like we we embrace the
weirdness but the world itself is very
literal and yeah it's just a kind of
it's the kind of voice that I like I
mean it's my voice that I like to write
in but it's it's the kind of stuff that
I want to see on screen so just making
things that I want to see I just
realized that everyone watching this
right now will not have seen it yet and
I hate asking the generic thing but do
you mind talking a little bit about what
the film is about and for all of you a
little bit about who you play sure yeah
well I'll start with what the film is
about it's uh Jesse plays KC a man who's
beaten in the beginning of the movie
within an inch of his life and decides
he's gonna take up karate to learn how
to defend himself and he at first it is
this positive influence in his life he
starts to feel more confident and he's
got a sense of like belonging to a group
now and something bigger than himself
but he starts to get kind of sucked into
the cult-like underbelly of the dojo
that's run by Alessandro Nivola his
character sensei and it gets crazier
from there I play Anna who is a female
character and and she is she's been at
the dojo for a long time and she has not
been granted the right to ascend the
hierarchy due to the fact that she is a
woman and and despite the fact that she
is brilliant she is not allowed to
achieve what she what she could so it's
sort of about her in a rage that comes
to fruition in
um quite a rowdy mana and her and and
they they meet each other in the film
yes a good idea yeah I mean um yeah
Riley kind of described my character's
plight so I don't know what I could add
to it except to say that it was the most
fun I had playing a character because
the way he speaks and behaves is so
unusual he kind of is like a child in
the way he thinks and behaves and in a
very sweet way - and that he is very
trusting even of people that the
audience is very aware he should not be
trusting
I play karate sensei who Jesse's
character comes you know seeks out to
try and teach him how to be a man and he
is probably somebody who may have been a
lot like casey jessie's character at one
time felt a lot of social anxiety and
felt sort of physically impotent and and
found karate and karate has you know
ended up becoming this you know sort of
devouring him alive and and he's become
a kind of you know symbol of toxic
masculinity and yeah so he he initially
takes Jesse's character under his wing
as in a kind of paternalistic way as a
sort of father figure and slowly proves
to be just totally unhinged I I've seen
a lot of movies and the the script and
the dialogue is very very unique
I would imagine when you three were
reading the script was it like as you're
reading it was you like oh I need to do
this you know what I mean because I
would imagine you don't get scripts like
this ever I thought it was the most
perfectly rendered thing I'd read like
every line is required to be in the
movie when we were on set every shot we
all as a crew and a cast understood
exactly what it was for I'd never seen
something so efficiently put together
and it was unbelievably funny the first
thing I asked Riley is if he writes
sketch comedy too because the scenes
were if they were to be played a certain
way could seem like broad comedy but
because there's this undertone of
sadness and darkness and danger and
these wonderful themes about masculinity
and the absurdity of you know
aspirations for you know kind of blunt
masculinity they're so uh you know
profound that the comedy is just kind of
like icing you know but these scenes
just the patter of these scenes is just
unbelievably hysterical I felt the same
when I first read it I just loved it I
absolutely loved it which is such a rare
thing to come across to have a sort of
wholesome response and all the ideas and
the argument of it was so subtle which
was so cool but immediately we're saying
this early we got so excited by the
style of the piece because you know
exactly your parameters in your
boundaries and what you can play within
and then speaking to Riley you sort of
like solidified you know as it was
written with real precision and just on
the car ride over here we were talking
about it and I was saying it was maybe
one of the first movies I've ever been
in where the film that I saw when it
once it was finished and edited was
almost you know like identical to the
movie that was on the page and insofar
as that like usually like scenes and big
parts of scenes are just thrown out once
you get into the edit just because
there's not enough you know real estate
to keep everything and suddenly the that
you realize this story is very different
from the one that you would set out to
tell and in this case it really is
exactly what was the thing that we all
read when when it was first sent to us
which is a testament to how precisely he
went about it and knew exactly what he
wanted to accomplish have you seen I
know I think the premiere is this
afternoon but have you seen the movie
yet with an audience because as I was
watching it there is a one or two like
holy [ __ ] moments that I think the
audience is going to go crazy I'm just
curious if you've had that reaction yet
I've shown it or during the lead-up to
locking picture I was showing it to
director friends I had
with like a few of people that I really
trust to give some notes and and so that
was a smaller audience and then prior to
locking walking we did a Gigantor it was
bigger than I thought it was going to be
but it was kind of a test screening for
a general audience that was unfamiliar
with anything about the movie other than
Jesse was in it and there was karate
involved enough said yeah they are in
and then yeah I I will say that I
Bharati I was I was surprised at how
just how uproarious the reaction was and
like you're saying that the holyshit
moments it if it felt like that in the
theater it felt like people were
genuinely surprised and there's there's
a moment where there was applause that I
almost feel like I teared up a bit at
the end of that and and then you like
kind of come to terms with things that
you need to fix and it's an eye-opening
experience you you make changes based
off of that but yeah that that's the
closest I've gotten to screening
anything but it wasn't finished at the
time so this will be the first time we
watch it completely finished with an
audience I'm excited for my grandma to
see this it's gonna be very I'm very
curious what your grandma's gonna think
she's gonna dig it without a doubt what
I want to definitely touch on there is
some great dialogue to your character
deliver some great insight if you will
where did some of that stuff come from
and how much are is were you was there
any sort of improv in the moment or
everything was in the script when you
got on set well definitely no improv
really I mean maybe we definitely change
Romeo and Julia yeah they're you altered
Chaucer there there was no improv in the
movie really but we talked about ideas
on the set but no I like H in terms of
like sensei's monologues or advice to
Casey in that that I it I liked the idea
of the student-teacher dynamic but
pushing it further than you would expect
and also using metaphors that people
wouldn't usually use like the
bear is still a bear a boat is still a
boat in the context of movie it makes
more sense it's still a boat like
projection and so yeah it's a it was
just fun to play around with that kind
of diet like even things that are
extremely dark if they're done in the
right way it can be very funny and I had
a lot of fun being very dark with sensei
I mean what he did so cleverly was to
have these big long speeches and some of
it is just you know makes total sense
and it's completely and without even
like blinking there's like a line in
there that's just completely outrageous
you know bizarre or offensive or
upsetting and it's just slipped in there
amongst all those other stuff and really
the way that we had to play everything
was just like run right through it and
so that the audience would almost miss
it but then you realize oh god he's just
laid that on me pulsing in the middle of
them oh yeah I really enjoyed the
dialogue tremendously I really
appreciate that before I run a time with
you guys I have to ask are you guys only
working together from now on
is there something that's going on yeah
it's mainly cuz of Jesse's wife and baby
that I just I'm a big fan as a team so I
just my wife thinks she's the funniest
person on the planet well it's been a
top 10 yeah I mean she we had done movie
like 10 years ago and and then when she
heard I was doing this jumps and jumps
obviously no-brainer and then she was in
movie in Ireland right right right you
you should say you so you filmed
something was it right after this you
guys work together again
yeah like a year a year yeah it was
about a year later yeah yeah it's by
Lauren Finnegan who made a short film
also about animals that was at South by
Southwest not about animals I think it
was something about a fox foxes Lorcan
had a short going around the circuit at
the same time the cub my short was going
around the circuit and we kind of were
friends friends through social media and
and email and text and stuff but I'd
never actually met Lorcan until recently
and while when I met up with him while I
was in Ireland he was just about to
start shooting with them and it was just
this cool thing where I was like oh he's
I call it sharing I'm pretty sure that
I'm gonna make sure I never work with
either I got to tell you after people
see sensei that we'll make a lot of
sense
sensei's a tough character um my last
thing for you guys I'm very I'm very
very excited to see the Zombieland
sequel I'm just curious what can you
tease people about it and I have to ask
you about why because I think the
thought of making that as a movie was
the dumbest thing ever and now that it's
a series I'm like oh this is the most
brilliant thing ever we shall see yeah
it's got good people behind it who
really care about it and I did think the
script that I read was really really
exciting and and the cost they've
assembled they're just super cool so
yeah we'll see what happens but I'm I'm
really excited about it for people that
don't know what Y the last man is you
should really make check it out yes yes
it's it's going really well we have like
two weeks left and it's just been great
like they wrote like maybe ten scripts
and different people wrote scripts and
so we didn't want to do it unless it was
amazing because it's not just like a
popular movie but it's also kind of a
beloved movie the people have like
personal feelings about you know I mean
so we had the feeling like it had to be
great and they finally wrote something
that was great it really is and you know
has amazing original you know concepts
that it's just wonderful it's been going
really well I was gonna say with the I
know you got to go but I would imagine
you guys wouldn't have done another one
unless you reach something that you were
like yeah exactly it wasn't that kind of
movie that you know doing a sequel to do
it yeah you guys have to go I'm just
going to say for everyone who's watching
absolutely see this movie when you can
it's great and really you guys did such
a great job with it thank you so much
for coming thanks for having thanks a
lot
you